house cleaning that's the focus of
tonight's angle
all right with joe biden at 38
average approval rating now 58 of the
country says he has the wrong priorities
and that election loss in virginia
now one wouldn't think that the mood at
the white house would be upbeat you know
pretty giddy
but it was all smiles today after the
early saturday passage of that 1.2
trillion dollar phony infrastructure
bill now remember only part of it is
hard infrastructure the rest is the
typical wasteful washington garbage with
a socialist bent
for biden's boy wonder transportation
secretary though it's really totally
awesome
when our communications team presents me
with copy i usually cross out the word
excited because i think it's overused
and i often rub out the exclamation
points because it's not always my style
but we are excited with an exclamation
point about what we're going to be able
to deliver
now it sounds like pete's got his
campaign commercial going for his 2024
presidential run there it is and let's
face it the democrats are going to be
wiped out in 2022 because we know the
generic ballot now has republicans at
plus 8 if you can believe it now by
historical comparison let me translate
how ugly this really is
in 2010 republicans won by 6.8 points
and picked up 63 seats in the house
wow
so just when pelosi and biden really
needed a win
well it came
courtesy of the republicans
this was a bipartisan action 13 house
republicans broke ranks with party
leadership a house finally passed the
trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill six democrats voting
against it and 13 republicans bucking
their party leadership
it was 12 men and one woman nicole
maliatocus from conservative staten
island who pushed the bill over the top
roads and bridges and tunnels and ports
i'm happy to have joined with my
colleagues to support this for my
district in particular i mean the money
in there can be used for all sorts of
projects i look forward to working with
my local legislators to identify what
priorities we're going to unite on first
off the congresswoman is not going to
have much of a say in how any of this
money is spent nice dreaming though the
biden cabinet is going to be making a
lot of the big calls and secondly
she conveniently leaves out that the
bill is laden with progressive pork
and it lays the groundwork for all the
climate change craziness to come
seven point five billion dollars is
going to go to elective vehicle uh
charging stations five billion for
electric school buses 1 billion for
ripping up racist highways and by the
way that's just a drop in the bucket
it's much more after that now no wonder
that dim-witted anti-trump menace adam
kinziger ended up supporting it
now none of them thought for a second
about what it is they're actually
putting in motion they just thought
about bringing the bacon back home
the leader of the moderates john catko
is particularly odious
but what could we expect from a
grandstanding blowhard who voted to
impeach trump over january 6th
now just as the capitol police protected
us
congress must match that courage and
protect the constitution our democratic
processes and this nation
the president's role in this
insurrection is undeniable
well since then catko has been a dead
man walking in conservative politics
months ago the powerful conservative
party of onondaga county said it would
not back catco's re-election
and he already has his first primary
challenger i love that good
now at least three out of the 13 washout
gop congressmen have already announced
their retirement get out the door well
good because each and every one of them
either didn't read the entire bill which
is a dereliction of duty or they did
read it and just ignored its most
egregious provisions which frankly is
worse than a dereliction of duty
a particularly lame pelosi inspired
justification for supporting it came
from congressman david mckinley from
west virginia
remember it's for the children he said
we've all heard stories of children in
west virginia sitting in parking lots to
do their school work because their homes
are not connected to reliable broadband
internet tonight i voted for those kids
oh really david
after watching the democrats destroy
west virginia's coal industry as china's
roars ahead
he now trusts the democrats to take care
of the children in west virginia what
planet is he living on
the fact is these 13 house republicans
are trusting biden's cabinet secretaries
to spend this gargantuan sum of money
do it wisely when the smart move would
have been to wait to pass a clean
infrastructure bill until the
republicans take back the house next
year
unless that is you trust energy
secretary granholm to focus on common
sense solutions to skyrocketing energy
prices
is the grand home plan to increase oil
production in america
oh my god
that is hilarious would that i had the
magic wand on this should americans in
what will likely be a cold winter most
of them are expect to pay
higher
prices for heating their homes yeah
this is going to happen oil and gas
companies are not flipping the switch as
quickly as the demand requires
oh my god is there
any more idiotic person who's ever been
a cabinet member i think
what we demand
madam secretary is an energy secretary
confident enough to answer basic
questions
not a 10 watt bulb pretending to be a
spotlight
again
this is the party with zero solutions
they only exacerbate problems and every
gop vote for this bill which is the
companion bill to the next even worse
social spending bill
ensures that current inflation lasts
longer and energy prices go even higher
now currently the white house has zero
plans to keep the latter from soaring
out of control
could you just lay out what those other
options are that he's considering so i
don't again i don't i don't have
anything specific here the president
spoke to this recently but he's also
asked fdc to crack down on illegal
pricing but also we're going to continue
to monitor the situation and have a
number of tools in our arsenal as i just
mentioned i don't have anything specific
monitoring
the situation that's always my favorite
answer
now what you all have to understand here
and the phony infrastructure republicans
don't seem to get
is that rising energy costs are a key
part of the democrats agenda they want
costs to go up
because they want to build back greener
even though it's going to mean that many
republicans will be forced to choose
what any many americans going to be
forced to choose heat
or food this winter
affordable energy means that americans
need less government and have more
freedom
they can have more freedom to do what
they want to go where they want wherever
they want
but the pricier gasoline airline and
train tickets become
the less freedom you have and they're
totally fine with that
now somehow the president's chief of
staff ron klain he believes that
tuesday's election losses demonstrate
that voters want more spending
i do think the voters sent a message on
tuesday they wanted to see more action
in washington they wanted to see things
move more quickly and three days later
congress responded passing the
president's infrastructure bill
well a new survey out by cnn shows the
main concern for voters
isn't infrastructure it's not equity
it's not racial justice issues either
what do americans think are the biggest
issues that he should be focused on
right now it is the economy 36 percent
of americans say the economy is the most
important compared to 20 percent who say
coronavirus that's now the second issue
while the economy is linked with the
supply chain problems the inflation and
energy costs by driving our nation
further into debt with spending
well things are only going to get worse
of course selling you out in the house
wouldn't have been possible though if 19
republican senators didn't sell you out
in the senate first
from mitch mcconnell to mitt romney the
old establishment decided to grab a
piece of the pie
one report notes that mitch's state of
kentucky can expect to receive more than
five billion dollars from the federal
package
again
as long as they get their piece they'll
just ignore the fact that it provides
the momentum for the build back better
bill which will cost an estimated 4
trillion dollars
no wonder the far left is ecstatic in
anticipation
it is a human infrastructure bill it's
transformational
the child tax credit when we think about
billion billion dollars for that climate
change
555 billion dollars there
150 billion dollars in housing
now the idea that joe manchin and
christian cinema are going to hold the
line for sanity
because the gop and the senate and the
house gave them a slice of
infrastructure
highly unlikely
every once in a while we get big think
pieces in the media about why populism
continues to be so powerful in much of
the country and why gop voters continue
to press for major change
the complete inability of gop leadership
to hold the line to do what where they
were elected to do and block over a
trillion dollars in wasteful spending
that's going to lead to more inflation
is a classic example of why populism
will continue to grow the establishment
won this round but their time is running
out
americans are not going to sacrifice
their living standards to keep the
democrats and their gop allies in power
we saw last week in virginia and new
jersey that change is coming
and the more harm the establishment does
to the economy
the faster and stronger that change is
going to be
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else